bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 15 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
accompagnés des invités mais aussi des
journalistes de la rédaction commence
tout de suite par les titres de cette
édition le club d'entreprises face à
lens et aujourd'hui cette job academy
avec le soutien de la fondation banque
populaire val de france
neuf salariés de la banque vont
accompagner neuf personnes en recherche
d'emploi durant quatre mois les
élections régionales terminées que
va-t-il se passer à présent vendredi en
ile-de-france valérie pécresse pondre à
la tête de l'assemblée
nous verrons qui sont les nouveaux élus
et 8 mois qui l'accompagnent naturel ou
factices les sapins sont déjà installés
dans la plupart des foyers certes
investissent plus de 100 euros l'an
dernier plus de 6 millions de sapins ont
été vendus dans toute la france et ce
matin je vous le disais en titre le club
d'entreprises face saint quentin en
yvelines a lancé son action job academy
porté pour la première fois par la
fondation d'entreprise banque populaire
val de france
neuf salariés de la banque vont
accompagner neuf personnes en recherche
d'emploi et ce durant quatre mois
le but de cette action proposé une
dynamique d'accompagnement dans la
recherche d'emploi des filleuls afin de
valoriser leur savoir faire et leurs
compétences un reportage signé william l
retrouvez une employabilité en est en
connexion directe avec les
professionnels d'entreprise c'est
l'objectif de l'action job academy
cette année c'est la fondation
d'entreprise banque populaire val de
france qui porte sa première promotion
avec le club d'entreprises face saint
quentin en yvelines
là on rassemble neuf parrain marraine
qui vont accompagner 9 filleul le but de
cette action c'est vraiment de permettre
aux filiales qui en recherche d'emploi
d'être dans l'entreprise donc d'avoir un
autre regard un regard d'un
professionnel est pas un regard d'un
accompagnant comme on peut avoir au
niveau du club face au niveau du pôle
emploi cadres ou du pôle emploi ou la
mission locale
voilà c'est vraiment un accompagnement
par l'entreprise les binômes auront deux
rendez vous par mois et ce durant quatre
mois pendant lesquels les filleuls
auront l'opportunité de valoriser leurs
compétences en organisant par exemple
des rendez-vous métiers ou des
simulations d'entretien d'embauché jour
d'hui pour philippe c'est une première
entrevue avec sa marraine
afin de confirmer le parrainage quand on
est en recherche d'emploi depuis un
certain temps on a encore beaucoup de
gens qui tout de suite vont essayer de
juger par des critères sélectifs des
grilles pour pouvoir sur manhattan
adéquat sur les composts la personne que
j'ai en face n'est pas là pour me
recruter
elle est là pour essayer de
m'accompagner en me donnant des conseils
voire à me donner des orientations pour
les prochains d'entretien donc ça c'est
quelque chose de très bons ça ne peut
être que positif jusqu'à présent
philippe a eu des retours qui lui disait
qu'il avait un cv très complet qui
l'avait fait énormément de choses qu'ils
allaient trouver très rapidement du
travail et pour le moment ça n'a pas été
le cas donc ça permet d'échanger de
manière un peu plus neutre que qu'avec
quelqu'un qui est censé porter un
jugement sur son parcours un nouveau
contact avec le monde de l'entreprise
mais surtout une écoute et un soutien
pour une reprise de confiance en soi
afin d'obtenir une chance supplémentaire
d'un retour à l'emploi
et c'est aujourd'hui la journée mondiale
de l'espéranto pour en parler avec nous
en plateau anne-sophie markov bonsoir
merci d'être devenu alors vous êtes
professeur d'espéranto au sein
d'associations îlots dont qui se tuent à
châteaufort alors pour le rappeler
l'espéranto est une langue
internationale qui est élaboré en 1997
par un docteur colonel jill saint lazare
zamenhof et son objectif était que
chaque personne ayant appris la langue
puissent l'utiliser pour communiquer
avec des personnes d'autres nations et
que cette langue soit ou non adoptés
dont le monde entier qu'elles aient ou
non des usagers la retraite alors j'ai
envie de vous demandez peut-être de me
dire quelques mois en espéranto tête de
vous présenter pour qu'on entende cette
langue que tous ne le connais pas tous à
l'automne elle vit seule automnale
chikyu auscultation espérantiste auj
elle l'a tout hammond chablais on est
pauvre vie des villes de saint john
alors je leur ai demandé la traduction
j'ai salué tout le monde non seulement
ceux qui sont sur le plateau mais aussi
tous les espérantistes du monde qui sont
susceptibles de voir votre émission un
jour ou l'autre
alors c'est un mélange d'espagnol et
d'anglais s'est pas véritablement un
mélange c'est plutôt une synthèse de
deux langues diverses que le docteur
zamenhof apprises au cours de sa vie et
il s'est rendu compte en réfléchissant
sur la langue sur une langue universelle
qu'il espérait offrir à l'humanité pour
résoudre le la punition de babel donc il
a il a pris soigneusement toutes les
langues qui ont été mises à sa
disposition
et il a cherché les points communs de
toutes ces longues ce qui fait que
chacun reconnaît dans l'espéranto
quelque chose qu'il connaît
alors aujourd'hui on compte suivre la
consigne à donner des cours les stars
ont tous continué très appris aux élèves
restés plutôt des années 1930 justement
un peu l'âge d'or de l'espéranto
on a justement demandé voilà à noah
nouveautés spectateur est une langue
internationale est toujours pertinente
aujourd'hui c'est la question que nous
vous opposez regarder non je crois pas
pourquoi je sais pas l'anglais est
tellement répandue cette fille a mon
avis oui oui pourquoi
pour que tout le monde s'entende je suis
pas sûr que ce soit une bonne solution
ça serait en théorie rapprocher les gens
et en pratique
éloigné plus les personnes sous un
masque de langage universel
non parce que je trouve ça marrant
d'avoir plusieurs langues à apprendre
c'est très bien ça serait bien
pourquoi parce que l'anglais sont peu le
but de l'anglais mais ça sera encore
plus large ça a servi ça a été une
utopie à mon sens ce qui reste une
utopie même si elle est pratiquée par
une ride j'en ai profité
en lituanie j'avais un ami qui parlait
l'espéranto et qui a pu très bien
communiquer avec les lituaniens dans
leur langage
mais après le royal est avant tout non
pas du tout le l'angle est actuellement
la langue dominante parce que l'histoire
et l'économie a placé l'anglais danse
est dans cette position de langue
internationale largement utilisée par
ceux qui nous gouvernent mais
l'espéranto conserve tout son intérêt
pour permettre une meilleure connu
communications individuelles entre des
gens qui ont envie de communes et de
communiquer avec avec d'autres qui ne
parlent pas la même langue et votre
reportage me paraît tout à fait
représentatif de dunes d'une ambiance
dunant d'opinion qui qu'on rencontre
régulièrement et
et qui explique que l'espéranto ne se
développe pas davantage parce que les
gens des convictions où il estime que
c'est inutile
c'est vrai que si on maîtrise
parfaitement le l'anglais on a
probablement peu besoin de ce d'utiliser
l'espéranto mais si on a envie d'une
communication différente avec des
individus qui ne parlent pas forcément
l'anglais ou qui n'ont pas envie de le
parler et bien l'espéranto permet de
d'avoir cette communication et de ce
point de vue là ce n'est plus une
cellule ce n'est plus une utopie déjà
depuis longtemps
alors cette année ya eu le 100ème
congrès je crois de l'espéranto en
france comment on fait pour réussir à
faire vivre cette langue s'il ya des
gens qui savent parler de l'athila de
transmettre à leurs enfants mais c'est
plutôt une passion comment vous faites
vous pour justement garder l'espéranto
on vit auprès de vos élèves
alors pour ce qui me concerne je
continue à enseigner l'espéranto à ceux
qui ont envie de la prendre
2 c'est évidemment une passion ce sont
des gens qui l'est c'est une passion qui
se transmet de spa dans four à quai pour
certains sans doute pour ce qui me
concerne
l'espéranto a fait toujours partie de ma
vie donc je ne voudrais pas de nécessité
à réfléchir au fait si réfléchir on a
toujours besoin de le fermer
je veux dire que je ne me pose plus
tellement de questions sur le
fonctionnement de l'espéranto juge
apporte des réponses à ceux qui me
demandent des explications et puis et
puis ceux qui ne veulent pas la prendre
ils ne sont pas obligés de la prendre
alors ceux justement qui seraient
intéressés qui voudraient apprendre qu
est ce que ça va leur apporter justement
est ce que ça va donner à des bases
grammaticales ou de sa porte des choses
aux jeunes alors pour les jeunes c'est
certainement très intéressants surtout
s'ils ont des envies de communication
internationale parce que l'apprentissage
de l'espéranto est très aidant pour
apprendre d'autres langues étrangères
puisque l'espéranto a été conçu comme
une synthèse des langues parlées par
l'humanité donc c'est une bonne base de
départ puisqu'il n'y a pas d'
irrégularités
les c'est une langue dont le vocabulaire
est fondée sur un patrimoine naturel
donc c'est une langue qui est
relativement facile à apprendre par
rapport à d'autres langues étrangères et
à partir du moment où on l'a apprise on
dispose d'un trésor qu'on peut utiliser
pour pour apprendre d'autres langues
eh bien merci beaucoup à nos souhaits de
margaux enfin sachez que l'espéranto
c'est à trente deuxième langue la plus
utilisée sur wikipédia par exemple sur
286 langues
nous passons un autre sujet à présent ce
week-end les manifestations pour le
téléthon ont continué de rassembler les
associations qui organisent des
événements au profit de l'afm le font
toute l'année et pas seulement sur un
week-end à elancourt le club de roller
airs le rock est proposé un disco roller
le moyen de découvrir la discipline à
travers des jeux des animations mais
aussi de s'amuser
125 personnes se sont déplacées au
gymnase chastagner cette année
l'association a rassemblés aux alentours
de 550 euros
les bénéfices sont reversés à l'afm
téléthon un discours roller c'est fait
voilà c'est tourné en musique comme dans
une patinoire avec un certain nombre
d'animations qui sont organisées au fur
et à mesure de la journée comme
des chenilles des courses pour les
enfants comme on a pu en avoir déjà tout
à l'heure et comme il va y avoir un
petit peu plus tout à l'heure aussi et
le but est de récolter le maximum de
fonds pour le téléthon qu'on a des amis
on peut bien s'amuser j'aimerais bien
coller que les personnes malades soient
guéris
notre ami on s'amuse et puis on est en
train de faire du roller donc c'est
génial on s'amuse en faisant quelque
chose de généreux autre initiative
solidaire mais cette fois ci dans le
cadre de noël samedi et dimanche
le secours catholique a organisé sa
traditionnelle opération 10 millions des
toiles à magny les hameaux
l'association proposé une vente
solidaire de petits objets comme des
livres mais surtout des bougies les
bénéfices serviront un centre médical
pour aider des jeunes cambodgiens
mais aussi à aider une cinquantaine de
familles du territoire de magny les
hameaux comme nous l'expliquent l'une
des bénévoles du secours catholique
écoutez la nous ici sur notre groupement
de manille or on a choisi de financer
principalement un projet d' aide aux
familles défavorisées
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
traditionnellement pour essayer de les
aider à sortir un petit peu du quotidien
faire des sorties en famille pouvoir
faire un peu de sport avoir des
activités de loisirs en juillet mardi
nous parlons accord politique avec
wilfrid irish hibon soir alors deux
jours après les élections régionales
nous faisons le bilan du scrutin
bonsoir florane en retour effectivement
sur cette élection la dernière avant la
présidentielle de 2017 au niveau
national la gauche a limité la casse
face à une droite qui a été malmenée
elle aussi par le front national
alors la droite qui malgré deux fois de
décrocher une victoire très symbolique
en ile de france jean paul huchon
socialiste régnait depuis 17 ans on
qu'on va décider de ne pas le soutenir
pour décrocher un nouveau mandat et
c'est le président de l'assemblée
nationale claude bartolone qui a été
désigné un choix qui révèle toute
l'importance de cette région aux yeux du
gouvernement seulement elle ça n'a pas
suffi vous revoyez les résultats
l'ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy
bientôt ancien député des yvelines
puisqu'elle va démissionner de ce poste
s'apprête donc à prendre le pouvoir
vendredi matin lors du conseil
d'installation à paris et à ses côtés
pas moins de vingt dix huit mois
certains sont connus d'autres un peu
moins
ils vont faire leurs grands les yvelines
qui ont voté massivement pour valérie
pécresse regarder tout d'abord ce
récapitulatif sur notre département
l'assemblée régionale qui compte 209
élus aura donc vous le disiez florane 20
élus de droite en provenance et des
yvelines mais aussi 8 de gauche et trois
du front national pour les nouveaux élus
côté républicain on peut citer pierre
lequiller député des yvelines ou encore
ottomane nas rousset le chef de file de
l'opposition au conseil municipal de
trappes il y aura aussi des
représentants du centre à leurs côtés
bruno myle yens que vous voyez c'est le
président du modem bibis modem yvelines
pardon ou encore véronique côté millard
là mais rudy et des clayes sous bois
pour le ps elle yvelinoise ramatoulaye
seule conseillère municipale à
mantes-la-jolie va faire ses débuts et
on notera aussi non pas une arrivée mais
un retour celui de benoît hamon le
député ancien ministre avait démissionné
lors de la précédente mandature de la
région pour éviter le cumul des mandats
ils se retrouvent à nouveau élu dans
l'opposition certes mais élu néanmoins
reste donc à savoir l'attitude qu'il va
adopter cette fois ci est du côté du
front national il n'y aura que des
nouveaux élus le fn n'avait obtenu aucun
siège lors de la précédente mandature
en 2010 le fn n'avait pas d'élus ce qui
n'est pas le cas donc pour ce scrutin
ainsi le secrétaire départemental
philippe chevrier obtient un poste tout
comme cyril note c'est le maire de
mantes la ville mais au delà du nombre
de sièges et des noms de ceux qui les
occupent se pose maintenant la question
des décisions quelles seront les mesures
de cette nouvelle assemblée écouter
alexandra du blanche pour les
républicains et les télés tiers sur
notre plateau pour une édition spéciale
du 7-8 politique pour débriefer tous ces
différents résultats c'est une adjointe
à sartrouville
elle va siéger elle aussi pour les
républicains pour la première fois en
conseil régional déjà on va prendre les
problèmes à bras le corps ce qui n'a pas
été fait depuis 17 ans il
la gauche s'est complètement laisser
embourber dans voilà dans les habitudes
dans l'inaction et donc voilà veille
pécresse quand on la connaît un peu
c'est une femme d'action
c'est une femme de parole et une femme
d'action et donc c'est ça plus de
sécurité à mettre tout à fait ça va être
ça la priorité ça va être de réorienter
le budget sécu le budget de la région
sur la sécurité il avait été divisé par
cinq par la gauche
quand on connaît
situation actuelle c'est assez aberrant
donc ça va être sa priorité également
l'emploi bien sûr avec une grande
conférence sur l'emploi au mois dès le
mois de janvier avec tous les acteurs
voilà pour les premières décisions de la
majorité qui sera en place on le
rappelle dès vendredi matin et pour
l'opposition maintenant une décision à
prendre faut-il reconstruire cette
gauche plurielle de manière plus solide
en d'autres termes l'accord conclu dans
l'entre-deux-tours entre le front de
gauche europe écologie et le parti
social il socialiste avait t-il survivre
à la défaite a priori les formations
sont pour l'instant sur la même ligne en
tout cas en ile-de-france écouter la
représentante
europe ecologie les verts dans les
yvelines jeu pendant la grande majorité
ils ont voté pour
pour le ps et pour bartolone parce que
vraiment on avait un accord qui était
satisfaisant et qui qui nous donnait
beaucoup d'espoir en particulier sur
saint quentin en yvelines au sujet du de
la ligne de métro des terres agricoles
de tout un tas de sujets qui nous
tiennent à coeur
on avait de l'espoir non non le résultat
n'est pas satisfaisant d'autant plus
qu'on a vu que les voix du front
national se sont reportés sur les
sur les votes
des républicains et les votes de gauche
la gauche s'est mobilisée les
écologistes la gauche de la gauche le
front de gauche à se sont mobilisés mais
mais ça n'a pas été suffisant et le mot
de la fin à présent comme toujours pour
les électeurs qu attendez vous
maintenant que la région a changé de
bord politique
on espère que ça sera aussi bien que ce
que ça avait été avec le ps en fait ça
va pas changer grand chose pour le
moment dans le sens où on est toujours
gauche droite droite gauche
la classe politique française est
vraiment très décevante et donc pour moi
je n'attends rien du tout je n'espère
aucune amélioration
je suis très pessimiste surpris non
content pour spécial mans apparemment
d'après la profession de foi et kretz il
ya beaucoup de janvier prévu on verra
bien j'attends beaucoup de choses j'ai
lu le programme de valérie pécresse qui
est plein de choses assez concrètes en
particulier sur les transports et puis
il ya un grand projet auquel j'attache
beaucoup d'importance qu'elle projette
paris saclay
merci wilfried prochain point politique
vous vendredi lors de l'installation du
conseil régional ce sera dans l'édition
du journal avec l'essentiel d'activités
que vous présenterez merci shon noël
maintenant ils trônent peut-être déjà
dans votre salon le sapin de noël c'est
l'élément incontournable des fêtes de
fin d'année et il est de retour
l'an dernier plus de 6 millions de
sapins ont été vendus dans toute la
france alors épicéa norman ou nobilis
comment s'y retrouver entre les
différentes variétés quels sont les prix
camille lambert est allé faire le point
à la jardinerie de chevreuse
petit ou grand élancé ou imposant à l'
approche de noël
le roi des forêts s'invite dans les
chaumières un choix pas toujours évident
même si certains ont une idée bien
précise de ce qu'ils veulent
eh ben j'ai choisi un épicier à parce
que j'aime bien l'odeur sapin de noël
plus que les normales si comme laurence
votre coeur penche plus vers la bonne
odeur du sapin il faudra vous tourner
vers l'épicéa avantage son prix c'est le
plus abordable mais les épines tombe
rapidement
vous pouvez alors vous tourner vers des
variétés plus résistantes
ça c'est anormal donc on va dire
maintenant le sapin classique qui
gardent bien ses épines
vous avez donc le fameux nobilis il est
là obtient un joli la suit la up
ça c'est le nobilis tout par rapport aux
normales c'est un petit peu plus bleuté
sap a exactement le même aspect puis
voilà lui donc il garde ses épines et
ils sont bons à la jardinerie de
chevreuse la vente de sapins représente
près de 10% du chiffre d'affaires annuel
dans les allées les vendeurs et des
clients à s'y retrouver
ceux qui viennent tôt en saison on les
dirige plutôt vers le nordmann où on
leur dit si vous achetez un épicéa
laissez le dans le jardin pour qu'ils
puissent conserver que qui reste beau ce
que quand c'est dehors ça peut rester
jolie des mois très bien pour l'institut
tns sofres le nordmann représentaient 68
% des sapins naturels vendus en 2014 sur
notre territoire dans cette jardinerie
le prix le plus élevé de 146 euros il
est donc plus onéreux mais même ici le
nordmann reste en tête des ventes
one a choisi un nordmann parce que père
passé
et donc dans la maison c'est l'idéal
pour un investissement sur plusieurs
années il ya toujours le sapin
artificiel
prévoyez un budget conséquent les plus
grands coûte aux alentours de 300 euros
et si la neige vous fait fondre il
existe des floqué un sapin recouvert de
neige synthétique naturels ou
artificiels plus de 6 millions de sapins
de noël ont été vendus l'an dernier en
france il ne vous reste plus qu'à
choisir le vôtre
et pour la deuxième année consécutive le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines a fêté noël deux jours autour
des fêtes de fin d'année entièrement
dédié aux enfants autour d'animations
sportives et artistiques de 1000
personnes sont venues durant tout le
week-end la structure a même accueilli
le père noël mélanie poquet et camille
lambert
à
cyclisme bien sûr mais aussi du cirque
ou des loisirs créatifs ce week-end au
vélodrome nationale ce n'était pas le
sport qui est à l'honneur mais les
enfants mais c'est aussi convivial c'est
aussi pour que les jeunes enfants
puissent venir c'est pas forcément le
lieu où ils ont l'habitude de venir avec
les enfants s'amusent profil de tout ça
et ça va des bons souvenirs là où ils
regardent les prochaines
mais pour les enfants le moment le plus
attendu de la journée c'était bien sûr
la photographic le père noël l'année
prochaine il devrait à nouveau y arrêter
son traîneau et nous restons vélodrome
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui organisait
la semaine dernière la quatrième édition
de son club à faire sur le thème des
jeux olympiques de 2024
le concept les partenaires commerciaux
de l'enceinte sportive se retrouvent
pour échanger et tester la piste des
activités comme des tours de gyropodes
et du granby comprenait un vélo composé
d'une grande et d'une petite roue était
également programmée dans l'air centrale
on écoute tout de suite thomas
boudeville le responsable du service
commercial de vélo police la société qui
gère l'exploitation du vélodrome
il était au micro dé michael almy
d'euros le but de ces soirées c'est à la
fois de permettre à nos partenaires de
rencontrer deux entreprises de créer
vraiment une communauté sur la partie
entreprise qui est voilà avec un lieu de
rassemblement qu'elle vélodrome
nationale et bien entendu aussi de
générer et ont séduit revoilà de
nouvelles entreprises et leur faire
découvrir ce site et surtout ce qu'ils
peuvent voilà il trouvé par un
partenariat
c'est bien parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de partenaires avec le
vélodrome que on est on est tous sur des
corps de métier un peu différent qu'on a
besoin les uns des autres je pense au
quotidien pour ce faire vivre donc c'est
important qu'on ait l'occasion de se
rencontrer et d'échanger
c'est l'union européenne façon vélodrome
donc on se retrouve
ça nous permet de créer des choses est
de renforcer l'activité sur la place de
100 printemps et pour finir ce journal
un mot de ce sport vous le savez sur
téléphonie vite nous aimons vous faire
découvrir de nouveaux sports aujourd'hui
coup de projecteur sur une discipline
presque inconnu enfle en france c'est le
floorball un sport collectif d'origine
suédoise semblables ok le premier club
des yvelines vient de se créer à buc
nickel elle me d'euros est allé à la
rencontre du club et des joueurs
regardez duo qu'amis sont la glace et
les patins le floorball un sport
originaire de suède créé dans les années
soixante dix débarque dans les yvelines
le club va aux bucs multisports propose
depuis septembre une section loisirs le
mercredi soir au gymnase du prés saint
jean
une première dans le département c'est
un sport qui se pratique avec une crosse
une balle creuse avec un gardien et on
joue à 5 5 contre 5 un match de
floorball ça dure trois fois vingt
minutes dont trois tiers temps de 20
minutes avec plusieurs lignes de joueurs
c'est à dire qu'on peut échanger comme
hockey sur glace tant qu'on veut pour
jour floorball deux éléments sont
nécessaires une crosse et une balle la
maîtrise de la crosse au départ c'est
pas évident faut trouver ses marques sur
sur la crosse donc il ya une prise qui
nous permet effectivement de maîtriser
la hauteur la vitesse même la position
du corps tout ça c'est important pour
arriver à ses fins et mettre la balle au
fond des buts donc il ya vraiment une
technique dans le floorball la balle est
très légère elle peut aller très vite
par contre on peut quand même se prendre
les balles qui font quelques bleus mais
rien de bien méchant
cette discipline compte à l'heure
actuelle plus de mille licenciés en
france et une trentaine de clubs abus
qu'ils sont une quinzaine à s'être
laissés tenter par ce sport pratiqué
principalement république tchèque en
suisse et dans les pays nordiques les
gens sont curieux les gens en vie décès
et on a pour faire de la publicité on a
essayé de faire baisser en initiation
faire la communication via internet les
gens sont venus on a une trentaine de
joueurs différents qui sont venus
l'adhésion coûte entre 95 et 110 euros
le club de buc espère attirer entre 25 à
30 adhérents d'ici la rentrée de
septembre 2016 et intégrer le
championnat de france la saison
prochaine et c'est à présent la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
tout de suite vous restez avec nous vous
avez rendez vous avec amis quel ennemi
de groupe qui présentera le 7 8 fort
avec tous les résultats sportifs de ce
week-end quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
le journal en direct je vous souhaite
donc une très bonne soirée